this program is brought to you by emory
university you know I think the double
majoring can be an advantage or it can
be a disadvantage i think that the time
when double majoring is an advantage is
when you're able to pursue very
different interests and the example of
the music student who also has a major
that's quite different than music would
be a good example of that that I think
that there you're trying to maintain
something that will be a lifelong
passion while also developing a career
path that's somewhat different from
music I think it can also be an
advantage as your interests evolve one
of the things that we see a lot is we
see students who their second major is
an interdisciplinary major and they
clearly have been led to this through
their own experiences fact that we have
a lot of students who double major is in
part indicative of that sort of
evolution of interests and an ability to
pursue even very different interests
while you're there and I think that
that's a great positive I think it would
be a bad thing if we didn't have double
majors the preceding program is
copyrighted by emory university